Guten Morgen, Thomas. Ich hoffe, du hast deine äh Datenschäfchen alle äh in einen sicheren Hafen reinfahren können.
Ich glaube nicht an sichere Efen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer einhundertfünfundfünfzig und äh heute machen wir mal ein kleines äh Spezial, was nicht nur damit zu tun hat, dass äh Linus gerade mal,
verfügbar ist für diese Sendung und ich von daher mal hier äh ausnahmsweise mal den Hut aufhabe,
sondern auch weil wir ähm ja heute mal wieder mal äh ein bisschen die Perspektive nach Österreich äh richten wollen und das sogar aus
zwei Gründen.
Nämlich einerseits, weil äh es ohnehin von Zeit zu Zeit mal angemessen ist, da den Fokus drauf zu richten und andererseits, weil ja natürlich auch gerade sehr viel äh Wind äh erzeugt wird
Wegen dieser Österreicher, die so viel Ärger machen. Thomas, ich begrüße dich erstmal hier.
Zur Co-Moderation bisher den Hörern eigentlich wunderbar bekannt und schon oft auch hier gewesen.
Ähm und ja, wir können dann eigentlich auch gleich mal zu äh Thema Nummer eins äh voranschreiten ohne viel ähm Teil zu vergeuden.
Und dabei begrüßen wir dann nämlich auch gleich noch den äh weiteren Gast, den wir hier noch mit in der Leitung haben. Ich sage hallo zu zu Max, Max Shemps, hallo.
Genau, du bist ja auch aus Österreich, deswegen äh konnte ich mir gerade den Witz nicht verkneifen.
Ähm ja, worum geht's? Äh ganz klar. Äh wir wollen natürlich reden über das äh Urteil,
des Europäischen Gerichtshof, was äh gestern so ein bisschen eingeschlagen hat wie eine Bomber, habe ich zu den Eindruck, weltweit.
Ähm zu ja ausgelöst durch eigentlich deine versus Facebook-Kampagne, die wir ja hier auch schon einige Male angesprochen haben und wir haben auch hier in der letzten äh Sendung im Prinzip ja auch schon,
besprochen, dass es äh absehbar war, wie das Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs ausgeht.
Weil ja der Generalanwalt der EU-Generalanwalt im Prinzip das alles schon so äh beschrieben hat und erfahrungsgemäß und so war's halt auch diesmal wieder hat sich das Gericht eigentlich der Meinung dieses Generalanwalts äh weitgehend angeschlossen
Ja, du hast das ja jetzt im Prinzip alles ausgelöst und ich wollte mal so ein bisschen die Gelegenheit nutzen, mit dir zu sprechen, auch um einfach nochmal nachzuzeichnen.
Wie es eigentlich dazu kam, wann äh wann hast du eigentlich damit angefangen mit der ganzen.
Das war jetzt zwanzig äh zwanzig dreizehn, ne? Hast du damit angefangen?
Moment ist das ein Fachbegriff, Rechtsmeinung.
Das ist ja interessant, die Männer haben sich ja im Prinzip ins eigene äh Fleisch äh geschnitten in gewisser Hinsicht.
Hast du denn ähm was hier ist eigentlich der alleinige Klageführer oder hast du dich jetzt beim EuGH auch noch mit anderen Gruppen zusammengetan, irgendeiner Form?
Ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass du keine Unterstützung äh erhalten hättest auf dem Weg dahin.
Das findet jetzt äh quasi auch statt.
Wie viel ist denn da zusammengekommen?
Und ist es dann limitiert worden.
Ähm gut, jetzt ist äh das Urteil äh vorgelegt worden,
Was steht denn da eigentlich genau drin? Was hat denn jetzt das EuGH ähm also was war denn überhaupt die Frage sozusagen? Also was was war denn sozusagen äh der Kerninhalt deiner deiner Klage und wie ist darauf reagiert worden?
Entschuldigung, du meinst jetzt äh Kernbereich der Privatsphäre oder Kernbereich.
Privacy International.
Kannst du das nochmal mit der Sieben oder Acht nochmal kurz äh äh aussortieren? Also was ist was meinst du mit sieben und acht?
Ist die Charter von der Mental Rides der Europäischen Union und das andere ist die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention und das sind zwei unterschiedliche Grundrechts äh Bausteine, die wir haben, die auch unterschiedliche Anwendungsbereiche haben. Weil das eine in der EU ist und das andere auch darüber hinaus.
Also das Urteil hat also EMRK, äh müsst ihr mal müssen wir mal aufpassen, hier bei den schnellen Abkürzungen. Europäische Menschenrechts äh Konvention ist damit gemeint. Ähm das ist das eine, worauf sich ähm.
Dieses Urteil bezieht und und die Grundrechte.
So, das heißt.
Wenn ich das richtig rauslese, hat diese Entscheidung schon ziemlich grundlegende Konsequenzen. Also das geht sozusagen eigentlich auch im Prinzip ist, ist das so in etwa das, was du erwartet hast oder ist das irgendwie mehr, als du erwartet hast?
Ja, aber es ist, es ist ja jetzt, ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher, ob bei der Entscheidung über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, glaube ich, hat ja diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte ähm nur so Peripher eine Rolle gespielt. Hier ist ja jetzt im Prinzip das erste Mal, dass äh die Snoaden League mehr oder weniger direkt
genannt werden, ne? Also nicht, weiß nicht, ob das Wort äh Snoten da.
Taucht, taucht auch explizit drin auf. Ist ja auch schon mal sehr interessant. Ähm.
Übrigens dort auch nochmal bestätigt sozusagen. Also wir haben jetzt schon mehrere Höchstgerichte, die gesagt haben, also das, was Noten sagt, das stimmt und das nehmen wir mit in unserer Begründungen auf.
Mhm. Na, das ist interessanter.
Äh das hatte ich auch noch gesehen äh äh sie meinten ja auch eine Zustimmung äh des äh EuGH, also jetzt sozusagen zu deiner Argumentation würde ja dem Schutz der Bürgerrechte und dem freien Fluss von Informationen großen Schaden zufügen.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt die Fragestellung, ne, also welche welche mittelfristigen und langfristigen Konsequenzen äh haben wir denn jetzt eigentlich zu
erwarten. Also vielleicht mal konkret, weil ja Facebook auch die ganze Zeit im Titel stand, auch wenn du wieder gesagt hast, dass jetzt nicht unbedingt die einzige Stoßrichtung ist, aber irgendwie ist es ja äh erstmal ein Kampf gegen Facebook äh auf den ersten Metern,
gibt es denn jetzt unmittelbare Konsequenzen? Also gut, du hast ja gesagt, das geht eh noch mal nach Irland und wir werden dann sehen, wie da im Detail nochmal.
Okay, gut. Und und was genau muss da bestätigt werden durch Irland? Also was.
Und haben die dann noch irgendwelche Freiräume, um das zu drehen?
Den irischen Supreme Court.
Mhm. Und das heißt doch, dass die anderen Datenschutzbehörden jetzt auch wirklich äh tätig werden können gegenüber amerikanischen Firmen, um die Interessen ihrer Bürger durchzusetzen.
Aber was ähm was erwartest du denn jetzt an an konkreten Auswirkungen? Erstmal für die US-Unternehmen, die jetzt unsere äh privaten Daten vorhalten.
Äh du meinst jetzt, dass welches Gesetz, auf welches.
Was erwartest du? Ich muss auch nochmal fragen, also was denkst du müsste jetzt, um mal erst mal bei Facebook zu bleiben, Facebook konkret für Maßnahmen einleiten, um jetzt gesetzeskonform zu sein?
Ja gut, aber was was heißt denn das jetzt sozusagen? Das heißt, wenn jetzt ein Deutscher dann äh äh Account hat, dann dann müssen die Bits in Europa liegen oder sie müssen nur in der in den USA genauso äh behandelt werden, als würden sie in Europa liegen.
Ja, zum Beispiel Silicon Valley ja ohnehin schon ziemlich äh auf den Hinterbeinen steht, was die ganze Überwachungssituation betrifft. Also.
So, wir wissen, deine Zeit ist äh begrenzt eine ähm eine Frage, möchte ich aber trotzdem noch einen Raum schmeißen, weil jetzt natürlich diese ganze Grundfrage mit äh die Grundrechte für Datenschutz werden hier äh verletzt. Natürlich ja auch Auswirkungen haben kann auf,
andere äh Vereinbarungen, mir fällt da vor allem hier Passengerecord, PNR, also die Speicherung von Flugcast
äh Daten beziehungsweise deren Austausch mit den USA äh ein und natürlich auch Swift, also der Austausch von Finanztransaktionen, der ohnehin schon sehr äh umstritten ist. Ähm denkst du, dass das
äh auch auf solche Bereiche jetzt ein unmittelbarer Auswirkung hat, die Rechtsprechung?
Und wie geht's jetzt äh für dich weiter, wenn du dann mal äh endlich äh vor allen vor alle Kameras äh geschoben worden bist? Weltweit.
Na ja okay, kann ich mir vorstellen. Thomas, hast du noch Fragen?
Nee, nee, ich glaube, das war recht guter Einstieg in das Thema, ja. Ich hoffe, wir haben dich bald wieder. Also äh es wird ja weitergehen bei dir.
Okay Max, dann erstmal vielen Dank.
Bis bald, tschüss.
So, das war der Max. Kommen wir äh zum nächsten Thema,
Thomas, was gibt's Neues äh aus Österreich, außer dass jetzt hier äh die Welt verklagt wird?
Ja, also das äh.
Das Tolle an Österreich ist ja, es ist so ein kleines Land, ähm und eigentlich recht unspannend, einem wird sogar ziemlich schnell langweilig und deswegen macht man viel internationales Zeug. So geht mir das ja auch mit der Netzneutralität in Europa.
Und da ähm stehen wir jetzt wirklich so kurz vorm Ziel. Äh ich weiß nicht, wann wir das letzte Mal drüber gesprochen haben, aber es wurde ja.
Ein Text ausverhandelt äh in diesem sogenannten Trilog zwischen den drei EU-Institutionen.
Vor der Sommerpause und äh die hat immer noch einige große Probleme, die uns Bauchschmerzen bereiten.
Trilog, damit ist gemeint, die Verhandlungslinie zwischen Kommission, Europäischem Rat und dem Europäischen Parlament. Mhm.
Und diese drei Unsinn haben sich da zusammengesetzt und Trilog ist an sich,
da gibt's sogar jetzt ein Verfahren vom Ombutzmann der EU äh äh weil die sagt, das ist extrem intransparent und extrem undemokratisch und damit hat sie Recht. So Trilog-Verhandlungen sind nämlich wirklich so, du hast davor einen
ordentlichen Gesetzgebungsprozess, wo Bürger einbezogen werden, zumindest theoretisch und Dinge sind transparent, es gibt offizielle Dokumente. An dem Trilog ist alles hinter verschlossenen Türen. Du weißt meistens nicht einmal, wer jetzt da wirklich am Tisch sitzt,
Und ähm das war auch dort der Fall. Also wenn man nicht irgendwie Leute kennt, die dort sitzen für eine Partei oder für eine Institution, dann hat man keine Ahnung mitzubekommen, äh worüber jetzt eigentlich verhandelt wird und,
das fertige Gesetz, das das kommt aus dem Trilog, die müssen sich einigen und ihre drei Standpunkte sozusagen auf einen Nenner bringen.
Und dass es da passiert ähm wirklich auch in einem Krimi um zwei Uhr früh ähm ist diese Einigung erzielt worden.
Ich glaube, ich komme mal diese Story erzählen ähm.
Wandeln jetzt überhaupt?
Das war äh Ende Juni, also sozusagen wirklich, glaube ich, dreißigste Juni, der letzte Tag der lettischen Ratspräsidentschaft, das wird ja dann mit.
Hälfte des Jahres ans nächste Land übergeben und die wollten halt unbedingt noch eine Einigung haben,
Und äh es waren schon irgendwie die Grünen und haben gesagt, nee, machen wir nicht mit. Die Liberalen sind aufgestanden. Äh die Linken waren sowieso nicht anwesend,
Und äh dann dann war irgendwie nur noch die Sozialdemokratie dort und da gab's auch irgendwie schon eine Verhandlungsführerin, die Kammer Ebert, die meinte so, nein, das geht überhaupt nicht. Und wir verhandeln hier nicht weiter. Die Vorbedingungen passen alle nicht,
Die andere Verhandlungsführerin der Sozialdemokraten stand mit ihrer Handtasche schon in der Tür, ja? Das war die letzte, die sozusagen, wenn die ja sagt, dann gibt's einen Deal, wenn die nein sagt, dann können wir mit mehr Zeit und mit mehr Ruhe weiter verhandeln,
Antis mit der Handtasche in der Tür gestanden und dann wurde ihr nochmal was für Roaming versprochen,
Hat sie bei einer Netzertralität nachgegeben, so sind wir zu dem Text gekommen, der jetzt hier am Tisch liegt.
Ähm und da wurden sozusagen die Artikel, wurden da Ende Juni festgezorrt, dann Anfang Juli gab's noch ein einziges Treffen, wo man noch über die Erwägungsgründe des Gesetzes gesprochen hat. Also die ganzen Erklärungen, wo auch Definitionen drinnen stehen.
Und da wurde ein bissel was noch repariert, aber es hat's nicht wirklich besser gemacht. Und wir wir haben stehen heute jetzt mit einem Text da.
Ja noch nicht wirklich gesetzt ist, aber der jetzt Ende ähm Oktober in zweiter Lesung durchs Parlament geht und wenn wir dort nichts tun, wenn's dort keine Änderungsanträge gibt, dann ist das so gesetzt und dann ist das die Netzzentralität, die wir in allen achtundzwanzig EU-Ländern,
diese halbe Milliarde Menschen haben werden.
Also im Sommer kurz äh zusammenzufassen, ne. Wir äh blicken ja jetzt hier auf einen Prozess, der schon wie lange läuft? Zwei Jahre.
Zweitausend im September zweitausenddreizehn ist das hat das angefangen, ja.
Genau. Und ähm
da gab's ja die damals ja wohl äh bejubelter und wir haben ja auch hier bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik viel drüber gesprochen, die äh Entscheidung des Parlaments, wie das wird der Netzneutralität eigentlich gehandhabt werden soll und
das war ja, sagen wir mal, ein Ergebnis, was sehr viel äh Freude bereitet hat und im Prinzip ist jetzt das Ganze im Rahmen dieser äh Trilogbesprechung,
aufgeweicht worden und geht jetzt in diese aufgeweichten Form wieder zurück ins Parlament. So, aber es könnte doch auch sein, dass das Parlament dem nicht zustimmt.
Genau, das ist jetzt äh äh auch der Punkt, wo wir ansetzen und wo wir gerade dran arbeiten, weil im Parlament, da sind halt gewählte Volksvertreter, äh mit denen man sprechen kann, die sich ihren Bürgern verantwortlich fühlen.
Und da versuchen wir jetzt in zweiter Lesung noch Änderungsanträge durchzubekommen. Für die Probleme, die dieser Text noch hat.
Ähm vielleicht bleiben wir beim Prozedere, also für diese Änderungsanträge braucht man zuerst mal die Zustimmung von Martin Schulz, vom Präsident des Europaparlaments.
Ähm das sollte nicht so ein Problem sein, weil es gab eine Wahl zwischen erster und zweiter Lesung, dann müssen diese Änderungsanträge von,
einer Fraktion oder vierzig Abgeordneten eingebracht werden. Da glauben wir auch, das kriegen wir locker hin. Ähm und dann werden sie abgestimmt mit einer absoluten Mehrheit.
Absolute Mehrheit heißt, dass ich nicht einfach nur von allen Abgeordneten, die jetzt grade im Plenum sitzen, die Hälfte aller Hände nach oben gehen müssen, sondern es müssen die Hälfte von.
Allen Abgeordneten,
auch die, die nicht anwesend sind. Das heißt, von den siebenhunderteinundfünfzig Abgeordneten brauche ich halt einfach äh fünfzig Prozent plus eins. Das heißt, ich brauche äh dreihundertsechsundsiebzig Stimmen.
Das ist immer grundsätzlich so, wenn ein äh Gesetz äh also wenn der sozusagen äh darüber abgestimmt wird, was jetzt die finale Vorlage ist für die Trilog-Verhandlung.
Genau, also das ähm sozusagen du hast ja die erste Lesung, das das Gesetz kommt von der Kommission,
Ähm dann geht es in Parlament und Rat. Die bilden sich ihre Meinung in erster Lesung.
Und dann geht's in den Trilog, da sagt man sozusagen aus diesen ersten Lesungen, die das den gemeinsamen Nenner, die gemeinsame Position, die verhandelt wird und die geht dann in die zweite Lesung.
Und in zweiter Lesung kann man entweder sagen, äh ja, passt, wird Gesetz, nein, weg damit.
Beenden den Prozess und damit ist das Teil auch gestorben. Oder wir machen nochmal Änderungsanträge.
Nochmal Änderungsanträge heißt, wir gehen ihnen noch eine neue Runde Trilog-Verhandlungen.
Und da können wir uns auch wieder einig werden oder nicht. Und am Ende wird was ausverhandelt, dass dann in dritte Lesung geht und auch da kann man äh ähm nochmal ja oder nein sagen, Änderungsanträge gibt's in dritter Lesung aber nicht mehr.
Das ist ein binärer Vot, ja.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Das heißt, man könnte aber im Prinzip jetzt auch sagen, äh wir wollen das überhaupt nicht, aber das ist jetzt eher unwahrscheinlich, dass es dazu kommt.
Also im Parlament ist es unwahrscheinlich, weil einfach Roaming und Netzzentralität ja die zwei Themen sind in diesem Gesetz,
und Roaming ist für die EU etwas, das äh in in breiten Teilen der Bevölkerung Wellen schlägt und das war auch Wahlkampfthema, als in ähm Mai zweitausendvierzehn, das Europaparlament gewählt wurde, ging's auch für viele Abgeordnete darum, dass sie vorher noch Roaming,
Abgeschafft haben und sich feiern haben lassen. Das heißt, für die ist das ein Wahlversprechen, das werden sie versuchen zu retten und umzusetzen.
Treppenwitz, wir erinnern uns, Roaming war ja immer so, dass das Tauschthema, ja? Wir wir nehmen euch das Roaming weg und dafür gebt ihr uns bei der Netzzentralität was. Das war der Deal mit den Providern.
An das Perfide ist jetzt aber, dass in diesem Text Roaming in Wirklichkeit
ähm weiterhin bestehen wird. Es gibt nur eine basic free Aloons. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie nach Italien gehe äh als Deutscher und dann äh zurück nach Hause telefoniere, äh ein paar Minuten, paar Megabyte habe ich frei. Danach gibt's immer noch Roaminggebü,
und wenn ich als Deutscher in Deutschland mit meinem deutschen Handy nach Frankreich anrufe, auch dann gibt's immer noch Roaming.
Also es ist halt bei weitem nicht so, dass wir an den Grenzen nicht mehr merken, dass wir jetzt eine Grenze überschritten haben. Ähm und dass wir wirklich als Europa zusammenrücken,
Ähm es ist halt gerade eben die die paar Urlauber, die es gibt, die sind aus der Debatte raus und das wird eher dazu beitragen, dass wir
Roaming auf lange Sicht noch behalten werden und nicht, dass es äh endlich abgeschafft wird.
Und hast du den Eindruck, dass das im Parlament auch auch so gesehen wird, dass hier eigentlich äh keine nennenswerten Fortschritte erzielt worden sind? Also ich meine, wenn man noch nicht mal das Ruming losgeworden ist und die Netzneutralität stimmt auch nicht. Ich meine, dann ist das ja wirklich ein schlechter Deal, ne.
Eine Rede. Das ist meine Rede. Es ist halt wirklich nicht gut gemacht und man hat halt in beiden Themen so.
Komm, lass uns Netzwerk beschließen, komm, lass uns Roaming beschließen, egal, was da dann drinnen steht. Ähm und es wird halt wirklich in vielen Teilen nicht, nicht hingeschaut.
Äh und da äh ja hätte ich mir auch mehr Unterstützung von den Konsumentenschützern erhofft. Die wissen auch alle, was in dem Text drinnen steht. Aber es gibt halt so dieses ja,
das Ding ist eh ausverhandelt, passt schon, gehen wir weiter zu Digital Market, zu den neuen Projekten und keiner will sich jetzt mit dem Zeug noch aufhalten,
wäre das aber wirklich desaströs, weil was da jetzt im Text drinnen steht, würde im europäischen Internet Dinge erlauben, die wir wahrscheinlich dann.
Nie wieder wegbekommen.
Ist ja auch ein bisschen absurd, weil jetzt eigentlich über diesen ganzen Verlauf der Debatte mit der Netzneutralität ähm sicher das Blatt in den USA komplett gewendet hat,
ja? Und äh weiß nicht, wie dein Eindruck ist, aber ich wäre jetzt auch nicht so überrascht gewesen, dass viel Argumentation.
In Europa ja dann auch eigentlich immer ne, grade wenn's um Internet geht, zeigt man ja schnell in die USA und da war ja so tendenziell eben auch immer noch die Debatte um eine äh entsprechende Verschärfung und Specialist Services et cetera äh spricht zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich hier die Gesetzesentwürfe manifestiert haben
und man, wenn man nach USA blickte, sehte man so, ja, wieso, die machen das doch auch. Jetzt ist es aber eigentlich genau andersrum
dass die USA sozusagen die Kurve bekommen haben und irgendwie begriffen haben so, ja, nee, das schadet uns. Äh aber die Europäer jetzt quasi äh äh blind in ihr Verderben laufen und äh genau das Gegenteil beschließen.
Ja, das ist das ist halt auch wieder so ein Treppenwitz, ja. Ich meine, als wir angefangen haben, ähm zweitausenddreizehn sah es so aus, dass die.
Da gab's ja noch die alten Regeln in den USA, die dann aufgehoben wurden, das heißt so, immer wenn's in Europa gut ausgesehen hat, hat es in den USA schlecht ausgesehen oder umgekehrt.
Aber es war nie beide auf der selben äh Seite und abwechselnd hat man dann von Lobbyisten gehört, schaut auch in den USA, ist Netznetralität, das hält dort nicht, das braucht man nicht,
und jetzt wo die USA wirklich gute Regeln haben, hört man von allen Telekom-Lobbyisten. Der amerikanische Markt ist nicht zu vergleichen mit dem europäischen und die haben ja viel mehr Olympohle und viel mehr Netzzentralitätsverletzungen
Also es sind halt Ausflüchte. In Wirklichkeit natürlich haben die USA hier einen Goldstandard gesetzt und
Thema wird halt gerade weltweit verhandelt, also in Brasilien, in Mexiko, wartet man, ähm also da ist man in der Implementierungsphase der dortigen Gesetze, da wird immer noch viel ausverhandelt in den Details, in Indien überlegt man sich in Netzzentralitätsgesetz zu machen, jetzt auf dem äh IGF in Brasilien wird das ein riesiges Thema sein,
also Netzertralität führt grade wirklich global ausverhandelt.
Natürlich schauen viele Länder auch nach Europa. Ähm wenn wenn die EU jetzt hier eine schlechte Entscheidung trifft, dann wird das,
Grund für vor allem viele Länder des globalen Südens sein, sich dann nicht an den USA, sondern an Europa zu orientieren.
Mhm.
Weil die Europäer argumentieren das ja auch so,
Dieser amerikanischen Diensteanbieter, die sind auf die verbrauchen so viel von unserer Internetinfrastruktur, die sollen noch etwas für den Ausbau dieser Infrastruktur zahlen,
kompetierenrissiges Argument, was man an vielen Eigen widerlegen kann, weil's halt einfach falsche Investitionsanreize setzt, wenn ich eine Knappheit monetarisieren kann.
Aber das das ist so gerade eben der Anti-USA-Ansatz, der in in Gefahr steht, in Europa zu siegen.
Was hast du denn äh für einen Eindruck, wer da jetzt so die treibenden äh äh Kräfte sind und auf jeden Fall jetzt noch Einfluss genommen werden kann und sollte.
Also äh es geht um Änderungsanträge im Europaparlament. Das ist unser Hebel, das sind wir stark. Ähm dort müssen wir vor allem,
ähm die Sozialdemokraten, die Linken,
die Grünen und auch die Paliberalen die es noch gibt die auf die würde ich mich jetzt mal so aus deutscher Perspektive konzentrieren. Es geht um eine absolute Mehrheit. Das heißt wir haben eigentlich nicht den Luxus
ähm uns nur auf eine linke Mehrheit zu stützen, sondern wir müssen wirklich mit allen sprechen, um genügend Stimmen zu bekommen.
Ähm und Safety Internet Punkt EU ist äh wieder aktuell, liefert wieder genau die Tools, die man braucht, um das zu tun.
Ähm das heißt, es ist auch keine eine Ausrede, wieso man nicht in diesem Thema jetzt nochmal aktiv werden will.
Ähm und äh wie gesagt, das Europaparlament, das sind auch Leute, mit denen man sprechen kann, die kann man anrufen, gerade die Assistenten dort sind alles irgendwie äh junge gut gebildete, doch meist sehr weltoffene Menschen,
ähm und wenn man denen erklärt, schaut, das ist wichtig und ihr habt das schon mal getan und es wird Änderungsanträge geben und ihr müsst nur die richtige, einen richtigen Moment die Hände hochheben.
Ähm dann wird man auf jeden Fall nochmal eine eine gute Chance haben, hier noch was zu bewegen.
Ähm was ich jetzt noch nicht erklärt habe, ist, was eigentlich jetzt noch das Problem in Netzneutralität ist. Ähm weil es ist nämlich ein neues Problem dazugekommen,
Wir erinnern uns noch, Spezialdienste sind sind äh jetzt in dem in dem aktuellen Text schlecht definiert, sodass bestehender Online-Dienst auf einmal,
Überholspur eines Spezialdienstes bekommen kann.
Also ökonomische Diskriminierung, da wo wie die Deutsche Telekom das mit Spotify macht, einzelne Dienste aus meinem monatlichen Volumen ausgeschlossen werden und auch wenn das Volumen verbraucht ist, kann ich noch Musikstreaming hören,
diese Form der Diskriminierung ist auch noch erlaubt und der dritte neue Punkt ist Glaspace Traffic Management.
Am Internet wird in Europa ja oft,
Bestford übersetzt. Best FORD, das äh Netzneutralität wird in Europa oft mit Bestord übersetzt, also dass Daten einfach genauso gut übertragen werden, äh wie man kann und ich ich äh greife als Provider jetzt nicht ein und priorisiere meine eigenen Daten
irgendwie meine Konkurrenz. Dieses Best-Efod-Prinzip wird eigentlich abgeschafft mit diesem Text.
Weil ich dann die Möglichkeit habe, als Internetprovider herzugehen und zu sagen, ich habe hier fünf Traff-Klassen. Und die Traffic Klasse, ich habe mal irgendwie goldpremium,
und extra langsam. Ich kann die nicht vermarkten. Ich kann da nicht ein Businessmodell draus machen, aber ich kann einfach sagen, Videostreaming ist wichtig. Ähm zeitkritische Dienste sind wichtig, werden immer priorisiert.
Webbrowsing ist eher langsam, das ist das ist in der mittleren Prioritätsklasse, sagen wir mal so drei von fünf und dann habe ich aber auch noch so äh.
E-Mail-Dienste, verschlüsselte Dienste, Dinge, die ich nicht einsortieren kann und die gebe ich in die letzte Qualitätsklasse,
Also alles, was jetzt an unbekanntes, neues Protokoll ist, alles, was vielleicht ist, auch wenn gerade da zum Beispiel Bitcoin,
oder betreuend Videostreaming über das Protokoll gefahren wird, dann ähm werde ich das auch in die schlechteste Qualitätsklasse einsortieren,
Also dieses Glas bis Traffic Management, auch wenn es nicht dazu taugt, ein Geschäftsmodell damit zu machen, hat immer noch große Probleme, wenn's darum geht, die Neutralität und Offenheit des Internets zu behalten.
Und ähm das wird eben ermöglicht mit den derzeitigen Text und das wirklich so reingeschlichen worden, keine vorherigen Institutionen haben das eigentlich in ihrer eigenen Position gehabt, aber es ist halt wirklich in diesen spätabendlichen Verhandlungen rein,
gebracht worden als Text. Und da müssen wir auf jeden Fall kämpfen, dass das verhindert wird, weil was mache ich, wenn ich ein neues Protokoll entwickle oder einen neuen Dienst,
und irgendein portugiesischer Provider äh gibt mich in die falsche Qualitätsklasse,
wie verhandele ich, dass ich da in die richtige reinkomme? Was ist wenn das ein Open-Source-Protokoll ist? Wer verhandelt dann dafür?
Was ist mit dem ganzen verschlüsselten Traffic, der vielleicht nicht kategorisierbar ist.
Es gibt Beispiele im Plus NET in Großbritannien, auch belgische Provider, die schon so ein klassenbasiertes Netzwerkmanagement haben.
Und äh das ist für ganz Europa, wenn wir in die Richtung gehen, halt wirklich eben genau das Gegenteil von dem, wie sie es in den USA gemacht haben und äh hat äh jetzt eben wirklich auch große Auswirkungen auf die Innovationsfähigkeit des Netzes.
Äh finde ich aber jetzt einen interessanten Gedanken, den du da gerade geäußert hast. Ich weiß nicht, ob der äh äh in eurer Argumentation auch schon eine größere Rolle gespielt hat, aber die nicht klassifizierbarkeit von verschlüsselten Traffic.
Im Hinblick auf die den potentiellen Anstieg von verschlüsselten Trappic. Ja, also gerade jetzt mit äh neuen
Mechanismen, die in den nächsten Monaten ausgerollt werden, wie zum Beispiel diese Kampagne. Ich denke, wir werden da einen signifikanten äh Anstieg sehen im im Kryptobereich beziehungsweise auch die,
komplett Verschlüsselung in großer äh Dienste, die ja mittlerweile auch Standard ist, äh
weiß nicht ganz genau, wie weit äh WhatsApp äh vorangekommen ist, aber über kurz oder lang äh wird es einfach noch mehr sein und das heißt, dass es betrifft ja dann im Prinzip alle Dienste. Also gerade diese Argumentation mit.
Ähm.
Ja, ihr seid ja nur ein unwichtiger Dienst. Ja und es gibt da keine Masse, äh in dem Moment, wo man nicht mehr klassifizieren kann, weil zu sehr verschlüsselt, äh ne, gerade wenn's alles ohnehin über Web äh äh Protokolle geht
äh in dem Moment ist ja jeder ausgegrenzt und da muss man sich wahrscheinlich schon mal darüber Gedanken machen. Aber wahrscheinlich stellen die Leute sich das halt immer noch so vor, dass man sich einfach äh den entsprechenden Sportwagen kauft in Form äh des des entsprechenden Netzzugangs. Aber innerhalb der Netze äh selbst ist das natürlich äh in dem Sinne gar nicht zu lösen.
Genau und äh das das äh da sind einfach noch ganz viele äh wirklich stinkende Eiterpollen in diesem Gesetz, wo halt auch schlecht gearbeitet wurde. Also man hat ganz oft äh Widersprüche auch im Text, dass dass man sagt so.
Äh der das eine oder andere Seite sagt, A, das andere Seite, sagt B und das geht logisch aber nicht zusammen,
Das ist halt wirklich so ein Kompromisstext und in vielen Punkten äh sagen auch äh inzwischen alle Rechtsmeinungen
ist das so offen, wie dir dann von den Regulierungsbehörden am Ende ausgelegt wird, also auch bei bei Spezialdiensten ist es so, das könnte man auch positiv lesen. Jetzt eine gute,
äh wirklich motivierte Regulierungsbehörde könnte sagen, nein, also es äh irgendwie so Skype Ultra hat, die ihr Spezialdienst, nein, das geht nicht,
aber es kann genauso auch in Regulierungsbehörde hergehen und sagen, natürlich, ja, wir machen hier den ganzen Markt auf. Und.
Genau diese Unschärfe im im Gesetzestext, die wird mit einem Arbeitsschritt, der
Ähm danach kommt beseitigt. Also wir haben sozusagen jetzt die eine Möglichkeit, Änderungsanträge noch reinzukriegen am, am siebenundzwanzigsten, achtundzwanzigsten Oktober, wenn das Ganze in Straßburg abgestimmt wird. Ähm egal, ob wir da gewinnen oder verlieren.
Passiert dann ein äh ähm Prozess, wo die europäischen Regulierungsbehörden sich alle zusammensetzen und nochmal Guidelines schreiben
die genau definieren, wie dieses Gesetz jetzt gemeint ist. Das heißt, es sind nicht gewählte Regulierungsbehörden, die Bundesnetzagentur für Deutschland, die RTR für Österreich, aufkommen für Großbritannien, die kommen alle zusammen
und äh geben dann dem Gesetz wirklich eine konkrete Bedeutung, die es jetzt noch nicht hat, weil jetzt kann ich's so oder so lesen.
Und äh diese Guideline Creation ist äh für uns deswegen auch ein ganz wichtiger Schritt.
Wo wir uns auch einbringen werden. Es wird da eine Konsultation geben, also es kann äh Hinz und Kunz und alle Menschen ihre Meinung sagen, ähm wie dieses Gesetz jetzt äh gemeint sein soll und und wieso dieses oder jenes wichtig und richtig für die Gesellschaft ist.
Ähm und da müssen wir uns auf jeden Fall auch nochmal einbringen.
Ähm da wird's dann auch auf Safety Internet noch mehr Informationen geben, wenn's soweit ist. Und äh das ist halt wichtig. Wir sehen halt,
eben in in Brasilien und in Mexiko sind wir gerade in dieser Phase. Da ist das Gesetz beschlossen und jetzt gehen die Regulierer her und überlegen sich, was heißt das denn eigentlich konkret?
In den USA was anders. Dort hat der Regulierer ja das Gesetz geschrieben. Deswegen ist das amerikanische Gesetz auch so gut, weil's wirklich äh
hundert Seiten lang hat. Äh und, und, und nicht wie das Niederländische, was fünf Seiten hat oder das äh Europäische, was so ungefähr auf zwanzig kommt.
Was ist denn dein Eindruck, wie die äh Netzagenturen, sage ich mal, äh dazu stehen. Also welcher welcher Konsens lässt sich denn da, also gibt's da überhaupt einen Konsens? Und und wenn ja, äh irgendwelche Tendenz schlägt das aus?
Ähm also das ist sehr unterschiedlich, womit wem man spricht. Äh es gibt sehr gute Regulierungsbehörden, die sehr motiviert sind. Ähm äh vor allem eben auch in kleineren Ländern und dann gibt es solche, ja, Behörden wie
ähm Offcom in Großbritannien ist so wirklich der Teufel, also die die versuchen alles um ja nichts zu tun.
Und die sind auch große Feinde der Netznetralität. Ähm an sich lässt sich das äh die Ausrichtung der ähm.
Der Regulierungsbehörden ziemlich nah an der Ausrichtung der Regierungen immer im Rat äh ablesen. Also die Länder, die
ähm im Rat gegen Netzzentralität waren, die haben auch meistens Regulierungsbehörden, die gegen Netzneutalität sind. Ähm der Vorteil ist so ein bisschen, dass innerhalb von diesem Gremium an europäischen Regulierungsbehörden. Berg nennt sich das,
äh jedes Land eine Stimme hat. Und im Rat ist es ja so, dass die großen Länder mehr Gewicht haben, mehr Stimmrecht haben. Ähm gleichzeitig
Ressourcen sind natürlich trotzdem ungleich verteilt, also kleine Länder wie Österreich, die kommen da vielleicht mit zwei Leuten hin, haben vielleicht noch eine Person, die,
halbtags irgendwie das die Verhandlungen verfolgt und äh,
kommen dort mit einem Verhandlungsteam von fünf Leuten und haben zwanzig Leute in London sitzen, die alles Myron und die ganze Zeit, die Verhandlungen äh begleiten. Also das wird wirklich ein interessanter Prozess. Auch die Kommission muss sich da einbringen
ihr habt da auch Mitspracherecht, das einzige Player. Und äh das das wird sozusagen auch nochmal,
Ein Detailkampf, den wir führen müssen. Aber jetzt sind wir noch im Gesetzgebungsprozess. Jetzt haben wir noch die Chance, den Text an sich zu verbessern.
Dass wir halt einfach um um Welten besser und erfolgsversprechender als sich jetzt schon auf die Guidelines zu konzentrieren.
Genau, das kann noch eine Weile hin sein. Ähm müssen wir halt mal schauen, ob's noch zu einer äh dritten Lesung äh kommt. Halte ich jetzt mal nicht für komplett ausgeschlossen.
Hängt jetzt vor allem erstmal von der Aktivität ab, die jetzt noch im Parlament entsteht, um genug.
Änderungsvorschläge durchzubringen.
Uh
Haben wir das damit ähm.
Ja, das war, das war sozusagen das Update zur Netzertalität.
Mhm.
Ähm äh ja, es,
bleiben. Es gibt auch einen schönen Countdown auf Safety Internet, wo man dann äh sich aktivieren kann, dadurch, dass jetzt noch neunzehn Tage, achtzehn Stunden und achtundzwanzig Minuten übrig bleiben.
Ähm das sollte äh Motivation genug sein. Ähm,
Ja und dann hätte ich noch ein anderes Thema, äh was mir sehr wichtig ist, äh zurück nach Österreich, äh das Staatsschutzgesetz, darüber habe ich mit Finus äh ja schon mal auch gesprochen, als wir als wir äh ein LMP dazu gemacht haben.
Ich weiß jetzt aber nicht mehr, welche Folge das war.
Das finde ich noch raus.
Ähm ja, was tut man irgendwie im Jahr zwei nach Snowden? Man schafft einen neuen Inlandsgeheimdienst.
Ähm also Österreich plant grade mit dem Staatsschutzgesetz äh eben so einen neue Überwachungsbehörde, die auch mehr oder weniger genau das tut, was jetzt auch in diesem Seehaber-Urteil kritisiert wurde, nämlich diese anlasslose Massenüberwachung.
Und da äh ist der Ackervorrat Österreich sehr stark dahinter mit einer Kampagne auf WWW Staatsschutz Punkt AT,
Äh und da, die haben schon sechzehntausend Menschen unterstützt äh
kann jeder machen ähm und an sich ist dieses Gesetz halt einfach eines, was
von ganz vielen Seiten kritisiert wurde. Also da haben irgendwie die Richtervereinigungen, die Bischöfe, die Arbeiterkammer, die Wirtschaftskammer, der Verfassungsdienst, des Bundeskanzleramtes, alle haben die Hände übern Kopf zusammengeschlagen,
geschrieben, wie könnt ihr nur ähm das ist halt wirklich von Hardlinern aus dem Innenministerium geschrieben und sozusagen der,
Wunsch jetzt mal alle Hemmnisse für Überwachung in Österreich aus dem Weg zu räumen,
eine große Datenbank, in die kommt alles rein, es gibt kein Richter Vorbehalt mehr,
ich kann eigentlich jeden überwachen, ähm auch Leute, die überhaupt nicht verdächtig sind, von diesen nicht verdächtigen Personen auch noch das soziale Umfeld, die Begleitung Kontaktpersonen,
an alle Daten, die ich da sammle, werden dann auch an andere Geheimdienste ausgetauscht.
Äh und äh solche V-Leute, wie sie ihm in den NSU-Morden verwendet wurden, die führen wir auch in Österreich ein mit diesem Gesetz.
Gibt's einen Namen für diesen äh Dienst, der da entstehen soll?
Ähm also das ist der der Staatsschutz.
Äh und äh der besteht aus den äh Behörden des äh BVT und der LVs, des Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung und der Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz
es ist ein bissel ähnlich wie die der Verfassungsschutz in Deutschland, wobei das in Österreich jetzt eine Polizeibehörde ist,
und sie bekommt dann die Befugnisse eines Geheimdienstes.
Leider in Österreich kein Trennungsgebot wie in Deutschland zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten mit diesem Gesetz bräuchten wir aber eigentlich eines, ähm anstatt sowas zu machen, verschieben sie's halt wirklich auf eine Behörde, die die dann eigentlich wirklich so wie ein Geheimdienst,
die bekommt das abstrakte Risikoszenario auf dem Tisch, es gibt radikale Tierschützer,
Und äh deswegen fangen wir jetzt an, alles zu überwachen und nach radikalen Tierschützern zu suchen. Und wenn wir dann welche finden, äh dann geben wir keine abstrakte,
Äh an keinen abstrakten Lagebericht weiter, sondern dann äh zeigen wir diese Leute gleich an und und äh leiten konkrete Ermittlungsschritte gegen diese Menschen ein. Also da ist halt auch genau das, weswegen man Geheimdienste und Polizei trennt überhaupt nicht bedacht.
Ja und das Gesetz äh es wird jetzt äh wurde schon zweimal verschoben, äh weil's so viel Protest gab.
Ah und jetzt äh wird der Protest auch langsam manifest im Parlament. Äh wir hatten letztens eine sehr tolle Diskussionsveranstaltung.
Mit den Justizsprechern von der ganzen Opposition und die Opposition ist geschlossen dagegen und auch die SPÖ, also die sozialdemokratische Regierungspartei, die in den Bundeskanzler stellt, ist in Teilen dagegen,
Da äh hatten wir den Justizsprecher, den Hannes Jarolim am Podium und der meinte auch, also mit ihm gibt's dieses Gesetz nicht und äh er hat da große, große Bedenken,
und äh die SPÖ sozusagen immer noch uneinig in diesem Thema.
Das ist aus einem anderen Grund sehr spannend, weil wir sehen in Österreich, dass das Parlament sich ein bisschen auf die Hinterbeine stellt bei dieser ganzen Überwachungsmaschinerie.
Ähm es es gab schon mal eine Resolution vor das Parlament, geschlossen die Regierung aufgefordert hat, jetzt endlich etwas wegen der Snoden-Affäre zu machen. Und alle Schritte in die Wege zu leiten, die Bevölkerung vor der Tätigkeit ausländischer Geheimdienste zu schützen.
Ähm hier ist es auch so, die Regierung hat das Gesetz durchgewinkt. Auch die ähm sozialdemokratischen Ministerien,
und jetzt ist aber im Parlament die Abgeordneten haben alle Bammel und sagen so nah, eigentlich wollen wir das nicht, also es ist für ein Land wie Österreich, wo eigentlich immer der Klubzwang herrscht und wo das Parlament eigentlich nur
Ausfüll äh Ausführungsgehilfe der Regierung ist, haben wir relativ großen Widerstand,
Das ist sehr unüblich für Österreich und ich finde das sehr bezeichnend, dass das eben grade beim Geheimdienstthema passiert und bei bei so einer undemokratischen Gesetzesvorlage.
Ja, interessant. Ähm meine wem also du hast ja gerade erwähnt, ne, dieses äh Trennungsgebot zwischen Polizei und äh Geheimdiensten, was ist in in Deutschland gibt?
Das ist ja nicht so.
Dass das mal einfach sich irgendjemand so ausgedacht hat, sondern dass es halt explizit gedacht, um eben so eine Bildung, wie äh man sie damals in der Nazizeit mit der äh Gestapo, nämlich der,
geheimen Staatspolizei hatte, zu verhindern. Weil in dem Moment, wo man sozusagen äh,
Undercover, also geheime, äh im geheimen stattfindende Maßnahmen kombiniert eben auch noch mit so einer
ähm durchführenden äh polizeilichen Tätigkeit in dem Moment übernimmt man halt die vollkommene Kontrolle und genau diese Trennung von auf der einen Seite nachrichtendienstlichen Ermittlungen, die aber so erstmal nur so informell sind
damit man halt Bescheid weiß, aber dann eben der Aktivität der Polizei. Auf der anderen Seite, das sollte halt getrennt werden, gerade um einen Übergriff des Staates,
verhindern, so wie er im Prinzip das ganze Grundgesetz ähm der Bundesrepublik Deutschland immer so in diesem,
Mantra geschrieben wurde man muss halt den Bürger vor dem Staat schützen weil hat sich ja gezeigt,
genug Anlass da äh entsprechende Bedenken zu haben. Ähm und jetzt kommt sowas wie eine Staats.
Staatsschutz auf in in Österreich. Werden solche Diskussionen angenommen in Österreich? Ist es.
Oder oder es ist halt einfach, weil die Nazis ja ideale Deutsche waren.
Ähm ja, also das ist äh man muss schon leider, äh ich ich beneide die Deutschen um das Grundgesetz, ganz ehrlich.
Es ist halt bei in Österreich weitaus weniger darauf bedacht genommen worden,
eine eine kluge Architektur diesem Staate zugrunde zu legen und man war halt mehr darauf bedacht, diese neutrale, schuldfreie Zone zu schaffen zwischen Ost und West und äh wo dann die Geheimdienste sich auch spielen können,
Wir haben ja die entsprechenden Gesetze, die das straffrei stellen, aber wir haben eben nicht so diesen.
Diesem Gedanken, dass man eben den Bürger vor dem Staat schützen muss, wie du das ja richtig gesagt hast und was, was jetzt wirklich eine Gewaltentrennung ist und ähm wie man auch ähm Pluralismus äh und und Extremismus ähm.
Immer da umgehen muss damit, dass das eben in einer Gesellschaft auch auf lange Sicht ein bissel resistent darüber ist. Ähm also da.
Ist in Österreich leider äh vieles nicht vorhanden. Wir haben auch keine gute,
Also die Bundesverfassung in Österreich liest sich wie ein Kochrezept wieder in den Staat aufbaust, aber nicht wofür steht, äh nicht, was er eigentlich will. Ähm und das ist an sich, was das äh ja, das das fehlt uns leider. Und,
Ich meine, auch mit diesem Gesetz, ich meine.
Es heißt ja auch schon Staatsschutz, ja, der, der Staatsschutz, der schützt ja wirklich nur den Staat, nicht mehr die Verfassung, nicht die Bevölkerung, sondern den Staat, seine Institutionen und ihre Funktionsfähigkeit.
Und er kümmert sich um Verfassungsgefährdende Angriffe.
Die aber auch äh ursprünglich Demonstrationstatbestände waren oder jetzt immer noch zum Beispiel Landesverrat, Geheimnisverrat Büssebleing, ist auch alles ein Verfassungsgefährder Angriff. Also da wird auch irgendwie so, da wird ganz viel zum Terrorismus erklärt,
was eigentlich äh äh ganz normale Straftaten sind und ähm auch äh gewisse Straftaten werden nur dann eben zu Verfassungsgefährdeten angreifen, wenn sie aus religiösen und weltanschaulichen Motivationen begangen werden.
Eine weltanschauliche Motivation hab ich immer.
Ja, das will man wohl meinen. Aha.
Mindestens nach den Regeln des Karmas, wenn ich jetzt glaube, mir steht mehr zu, auch dann habe ich eine weltanschauliche Motivation,
und äh äh natürlich auch Religion ist jetzt auch kein Schwernisgrund, wenn jemand irgendjemand anderen aus religiösen Um äh Gründen bestiehlt oder so, dann,
dann ist es auch noch kein Ding, ja? Und deswegen haben ja auch die Bischofskonferenz und die evangelische Kirche auch gesagt, äh äh das ist das falsche Abgrenzungskriterium und hust, hust, was ist mit unserem Beichtgeheimnis? Das nimmt ihr uns ja auch gerade weg.
Ähm also die die Kritik war wirklich aus allen Teilen der Gesellschaft damals, das das hat uns auch sehr bestärkt und das wirkt immer noch nach.
Und es ist halt auch zum ersten Mal, wo ich sehe, so okay,
Wir haben jetzt echt eine große Mobilisierung. Wir haben viele Leute, die in Österreich gegen dieses Gesetz inzwischen aktiv werden. Und da ähm.
Ja, da äh äh habe ich durchaus noch Hoffnung, dass wir es schaffen, dass das jetzt im parlamentarischen Prozess äh entweder komplett abgeschafft wird oder mit Änderungsanträgen noch so weit
alle Giftzähne gezogen werden. Das ist dann halt wirklich den Namen verdient in einem polizeilichen Staatsschutzgesetzes, was keine Geheimdienste mehr beinhaltet.
Ähm das hast du gesagt, die Abstimmung ist zum zweiten Mal verschoben worden. Ist sie erstmal auf unbestimmte Zeit oder auf ein konkretes Datum äh verschoben worden?
Auf unbestimmte Zeit, dass es in Österreich auch wieder sehr super
man erfährt das dann irgendwann kurzfristig, wann etwas auf die Tagesordnung kommt. Im Moment steht's noch nicht fest. Es wird wahrscheinlich am achtundzwanzigsten Oktober einen Innenausschuss geben, wo dieses Gesetz beschlossen äh werden soll oder wo mal im Ausschuss drüber verhandelt werden soll. Das hat auch die Frage, wie durchsetzungsstark sind die Abgeordneten
noch ein geben, wie viele Änderungsanträge gibt's im im Ausschuss schon.
Ähm das ist sozusagen der erste Schritt und im November wär dann eben das Plenum, das frühestmögliche wo man es beschließen könnte, ein Treppenwitz noch, ja.
Achtundzwanzigsten Oktober,
der Innenausschuss eigentlich vom amerikanischen Kongress über die Geheimdiensttätigkeit der NSE sprechen sollen und die Bedenken der österreichischen Bevölkerung, dem amerikanischen Kongress ausdrücken,
und dieser Termin, wo Österreich sozusagen im Nachgang dieses Ganzes auf die Hinterbeine stellen, in den USA vollständig wird. Der Termin muss jetzt wahrscheinlich abgesagt werden, weil die Innenministerin,
das Staatsschutzgesetz, also den Ausbau der eigenen Überwachung,
lieber haben will. Ähm das das zeigt schon sehr, wo die Prioritäten liegen. Ähm und äh auch schön, wenn das Gesetz dann wirklich im elften, zwölften November beschlossen werden sollte,
Ähm zwölfter November neunzehnhundertachtzehn ist der Tag, wo die erste Republik ausgerufen wurde, also für Österreich die absolute Monarchie abgeschafft hat,
vielleicht jetzt zum selben Tag auch wieder abgeschafft.
Ja, der AK Vorrat äh macht da entsprechend ähm.
Stimmung gegen diese Gesetzespläne? Gibt's da irgendetwas, den man sich konkret anschließen sollte? Außer der allgemeinen Diskussion.
Ja, also äh WWW Punkt Staatsschutzer T ist so die die Kampagnenseite, da findet man mehr oder weniger alles, oder AKVAT, das ist eben die äh Web,
der NGO, für die ich auch arbeite, das ist äh ich ich äh habe hier zum ersten Mal auch wirklich ähm mache das hauptberuflich für diese Kampagne. Europäisch ist natürlich auch
wichtig, aber da hast du halt immer ein großes Netzwerk von verschiedenen Playern,
hier ist wirklich auch ein tolles Team dahinter und es gibt inzwischen ganz viele Materialien, auf die ich stolz bin, die erklären, wo liegt das Problem, wer hat sich alle geäußert,
Das ist auf jeden Fall einen Blick wert.
Man kann die Petition unterstützen, damit leistet man auch einen Beitrag. Äh wie gesagt, das haben schon sechzehntausend Menschen gemacht. Das können noch viel mehr werden.
Gut, das werden wir alles äh verlinken, so wie es hier guter Stil ist. Äh in den Netzpolitik Punkt DE.
Hast du sind wir durch mit dem Thema jetzt.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben's.
Gut, dann gehen wir jetzt in den in entspannten äh äh Pilot über. Was wolltest du fragen?
Na, ich wollte nur fragen, ob man eigentlich dieses WWW noch dazu sagt für Domains, ich habe mir das letztens wieder angewohnt, nachdem ich's nie gemacht habe.
Ähm aber ich ich glaube, das hier ist nicht das Publikum, wo wir das noch dazunehmen muss, aber es es wird dann teilweise so gefragt, brauche ich da das WWW davor? Das sind noch Fragen, die die einem gestellt werden, wenn man so vor allem mit älteren Semestern spricht.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage und ähm ich denke, das Ding ist eigentlich durch.
Weltweit Web hat sich abgelöst, oder?
Es es wäre, wäre sicherlich ganz angemessen noch die entsprechenden Ali, also einfach stumm äh einzubauen, um ganz sicher zu gehen, weil's ja dann auch, was weiß ich
immer noch so merkwürdige, automatische Complition-Mechanismen, die vielleicht irgendwo gefragt noch WWWs davor schreiben, weil kann ja sein, ne, da sollte man zumindest drauf achten, dass in dem Fall nicht eine ganz andere Webseite äh auf einmal
zu zum Tage kommt, weil man das halt einfach selber nicht mehr so testet.
Ja das das sind auf jeden Fall ist da wichtig.
Im Webverkehr. Gut, ich denke, da machen wir den Sack jetzt einfach mal zu, Thomas
Vielen, vielen Dank für äh die Ausführung und ähm ihr könnt euch ja auch mal hier Thomas äh Vorträge zu den zahlreichen Themen äh anschauen, haben wir auch äh verlinkt hier in den. Ja und.
Nächste Woche geht's dann auch wieder weiter mit Linus, denke ich. Und äh bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und sage tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao. Cool. So, ich komme auf eine Stunde dreizehn.